[Music]
and break up to make up new submitted by
blow the whistle
a couple went on a sixty one day break
up trip break up trip what's a break up
truth these are the people that weird me
out there always there do the people who
are like we're really cool actually like
a little too much and they don't work
because 61 days for a vacation just to
spend doing jack [ __ ] that's a lot of
[ __ ] money who came up with 61 yeah
yeah number maybe they just counted how
long it took for them to be on vacation
these are like those weird people want
super petty with their exes
and I don't like it i don't know i don't
like that i don't like that friendship
stuff you break down like we're still
cool though we're still I don't
understand I'm not what this is can can
you please explain okay so this young
couple here they're from China
their love story went viral as they went
on a sixty one day breakup trip so the
guy his name is poopoo pu pu Chinese
name I don't know I guess it is is it
poopoo I don't know that's your name
that just gives joy to the world guys
and the woman her name is peepee
they're meant to be together
Ju eat you yeah it's pronounced P P P P
I like this couple they met when they
were studying together I mean they were
studying in college and oh they're in
college popped out University
so then after graduation pupu returned
to his hometown to be a teacher and then
PP stays in the city to work as a comic
artist oh oh oh we had this
long-distance relationship but
eventually which I don't know how much
time went by but they decided that it
was just too hard to keep his
long-distance relationship going and so
they decided to go on this breakup trip
to eventually break up oh so it wasn't a
real [ __ ] hate you break up it was
more like man we just miss each other so
much it's too tough to like try to keep
this holding on for like long distance
never know how far away they lived from
each other either but anyway they did
the 61 day trip throughout China then
they got married so they ended up going
to nine cities and they documented
everything on Weibo and they also had
this countdown of the day that they had
left and status updates and so on the
last day of the trip they decided to
stay together no yeah they did the one
thing they needed to do to really spend
time bent on this this seems like it's
all staged because how do you have time
to take a 61 day trip but not have time
to see each other well cuz now there's
like oh no there's like something that
they're risking there's something on the
line now huge a huge motivation it
sounds like two people that are half
stepper that are half steppers yeah
they're kind of like not not fully
committed not sure and and they're just
they can't really say what they want so
one probably thinks the other one wants
to break up so they do it first anyway
kind of stuff
[Music]
they look like they had a lot of fun
yeah damn 61 days is a long last time
it's wait you want to be on vacation
and people are like cutting out the time
how do you have the money to do this but
not to invest that into your actual
relationship so people are like this is
just all staged and were they reminding
each other like every week of like you
know we're still bringing up after 6
in-1 days you know like after the last
days you know mean like still we're
still down for this at the point of
breaking up with someone the last thing
you want to do is go on vacation with
them yeah [ __ ] hate you I don't even
I don't need a [ __ ] trip away from
this world with the assumption that you
guys hate each other but with this one
it just sounded like their lives were
separate and they were so busy that they
couldn't commit a hundred percent to
each other so didn't seem like they
hated each other it just seemed like
they respected each other if anything
there's nowhere I could go for 61 days
without starting to hate it at some
point like every time I'm on vacation it
goes too long like you get that oh for
sure
but what if you're City hopping because
it's not the same city with the same
thing I just gotta be home can you say
though I did a trip through Europe with
Nicky where we went to a different city
every two days and it was just a
nightmare because like you're traveling
every two days so you don't ever get to
settle anywhere
I said check it out like you're just 61
days to check out nine cities it sounds
like they settled each city yeah I would
just go crazy being away from home for
61 days no thank you
yeah do you like your home base huh
mm-hmm I like my home to actually i
recharge there man especially now that
I'm 30 I'm like man this one go home I
know it's gonna be homeless okay I have
responsibilities though it's one or the
other you can't have both lives okay
it's crazy how how did the switch
happens I think about they're like
randomly it so had like damn I was a kid
and that was a whole different world of
like like out cuz I I try thinking about
like I get lost in my thoughts that I
have now
go what were the thoughts I was getting
lost in as a kid I were those thoughts
were on this line man I was like what
those stars that I was having as a kid
that has nothing to do with
responsibilities like Bill's like oh I'm
gonna take care of rent how I'm going to
take care of these things like having a
hot like a home and being an adult you
didn't have those responsibilities to
your homies to hanging out to look and
cool to fitting in like those that was
your job
one backstrap or two yeah that was a big
deal you know like Who am I gonna go to
the dance with hang out with these
people cuz then if I keep it with these
people they're kind of lame whatever
wish dress would be what would you would
you guys rather have the stress that is
like have responsibilities of being
adult was stressful blah blah being an
adult life so many more doors I want to
be a kid but with cool parents see I
always had the shadow I remember being a
kid actually in my thoughts I remember
always wanting always wanting money cuz
I remember my mom crying on the phone
about money a lot so yes so I was always
like man if I could just make my [ __ ]
million dollars like sounds kind of the
same Jam that was my thing and it it
turned like it really turned on me
because like as a kid that does the same
thing with my mom like my parents split
of like you know my paws wasn't helping
like with uh with like child support
stuff so then it ends up being a thing
where my mom's just doing like multiple
jobs and stuff so I'm thinking like you
know what I don't want to keep asking
y'all for the shoes for school or the
you know all the stance on me I'm gonna
just work for mine I ended up like
getting like so focused on that like
when I got my first job I my car myself
and and I was kind of like I'm doing my
own thing with that my mom was like like
are you gonna help like you know what
groceries you're gonna help and I didn't
even think about that I felt so bad the
dad bought my car that's why you guys
don't want to be kids
I got the the hundreds all across the
table like child loving I'm out to get
my car you know me and my mom told my
brother when I was on my way to get my
car she was like venting to my brother
like dang like he was so happy to have
all that money and didn't want to give
like 100 bucks
you know for like groceries so this
whole thing my brother told me that my
mom said that I was like you know I
wouldn't even hype about my car like Oh
what did you saw your car she had a ruin
all that for you as you saw your car
give her some money
no you weren't that high pavada time I'd
say you were pretty high but the car
then you weren't that high but helping
mom were you know that's what that's
what I'm saying no we could switch it
and she also was like she also said
something like is that she had oh she
had put the insurance on it so she also
could I was kind of like I'm doing my
own thing I got my car she's like what
she put their insurance on so she's like
she still has to say you know me so I'm
like oh alright well I'm still a little
[ __ ] what was with the child support
thing your old man wasn't kicking into
that yeah it was a rough little
situation you know mean like you know
dealing with like my much my dad was
told it during that child his first word
he was totally against like heavens
divorcee and and the idea of child
support and I understand the perspective
he's like I want the money to go
straight to the kids not understanding
that the money is going towards you know
even the house or groceries always
saying that's still going towards it but
he's black now I'll rather give this
whatever out of my checks directly to my
kids you know that that was like his
thing but and so it was just so I get
that mentality yeah y'all have [ __ ] up
childhoods that's why you want to be a
kid again now my good job you don't
remember the feeling that you got at the
Halloween parade in elementary school
you telling me you don't want to relive
that [ __ ] I don't remember that that was
the [ __ ] [ __ ] I couldn't wait to get
in my costume and walk inside the
Halloween parade where we all lined up
and walk in a [ __ ] big loop around
the track but it's because I couldn't
afford the we couldn't buy the costume I
wanted see that's why joy I combined any
of you know what no I mean I didn't
never get the best custom but I know how
to have fun man you still do I remember
one year I went as Batman but then I
also went as on me as another guy so
that I got to be both and so I left all
my friends cuz they're like hey what's
up Steve like while I was Batman yeah
but then I went up to those same friends
like an hour later and I was like what's
up dudes and they're like wait weren't
you Batman I was like no oh my god
you've always been a [ __ ] troll
yeah one year my mom made me wear a USC
sweaters that could be a student for
Halloween oh my god Wow that's creative
it's really fun hey what are you a
student that's really terrible you're
crying for like an hour before school
you're like why do I have the most
lamest costume in the [ __ ] world even
in the [ __ ] fun part she has to make
sure that you're still being brainwashed
to go to a good school that's [ __ ] it
worked
Oh cuz you did I mean you don't let me
alone about it didn't pretty good to you
you never know that so y'all need to do
what I do and just suppress all the bad
[ __ ] oh it's non-existent you just
forget completely and then you have a
blast cuz all your memories are positive
man I tried having that and I had this
random like like like um what is it
outbursts to my mom like when I was out
here actually in LA it's gonna happen
from time to time bad but the rest is
okay if you're laughing all the people
around you're all crying and [ __ ] you're
like but I feel good 64 364 good days in
one meltdown day oh man that that
meltdown was crazy in that and that and
I will start it was my first time
standing up to my mom like it was like I
thought it was a selfish situation that
she left my dad I didn't want to leave
my you know this all day and then
thinking thinking about her perspective
everything I learned that it's really
about your own happiness
you mean like she's not happy with
somebody then she wants to be happy you
know and I'm not thinking about that I'm
thinking like yo I gotta live this weird
life like all my friends they got their
parents didn't mean like blaming them
yeah yeah and then and then my dad's
perspective - you don't mean like
figuring out like how now he don't have
a family or like you know his kids or
you know so that hole all those things
like hold the holding all in and I was
like it just randomly just came out you
know like how many years later after the
doors oh that was so that was already
like 1012 years like yeah I didn't know
that was like like you saying like I
didn't know it was something that was
really bothering me it was just it was
just I all right y'all are
you're doing this day and then you know
I still do what I got to do and then I'm
trying to pursue something so I'm going
to LA I'm always on this like I had the
middle child syndrome so I'm like you
got to prove yourself yeah yeah so I was
always in but I didn't know why I had
this such see that's why you can't make
peace or else you'll never want to be
famous that's true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]